[Music]
this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrasse
tyson your personal
astrophysicist i got with me chuck nice
jet
hey neil what's happening you're my man
about town my co-host
thank you the man the man about town who
stays home
all the time okay sorry
okay you're mad about home okay there
you go the man about house
about house you are the man of our house
my my co-host
and stand-up comedian and today's topic
is going to be
one of many times we've explored
how science is working in the science
fiction
that we're all exposed to some of us are
bathed in
and we're going to be featuring my
interview with novelist
engineer turned novelist andy weir oh
your buddy
my buddy he's the author of the martian
exactly so we're gonna bring him on uh
but we have in studio in our sort of
virtual zoom studio a friend of star
talk
david grinspoon david welcome back to
star talk dr
funky spoon monkey spoon yes and why are
we calling it
that's you that's your twitter handle
right doctor yeah yeah it's great to see
you guys and it's great to to be here
wherever here is
excellent so i think we count you among
the ranks of official astrobiologists
right you're also an author
a writer and with that hat and your
twitter handle of funky spoon
we also learned that you're a musician
so
we love that combination uh you're a
senior scientist at the planetary
science institute i think they're based
in in arizona
um but you spend most of your time in
washington is that correct
yeah cpsi planetary science institute
has the mothership in arizona but
we're sort of a distributed institute
and a lot of us are all over and i'm in
washington dc
we were doing this virtual connection
thing before before it was cool before
[Laughter]
so you've got a recent book author of
several books i remember your early book
on venus
uh that was fun uh aren't many books on
venus and you put one out there on it
so uh but more recently you've got a
book titled
chasing new horizons yeah which was
new horizons was the actual name of a
space mission so you did a double
meaning there chasing new horizons
inside the epic
first mission to pluto and you
co-authored that with mr pluto himself
alan stern and just a little bit more on
your background
you won the prestigious carl sagan medal
for
public communication communication of
planetary science
so there's no higher award given by
the american astronomical society uh for
that role
and you you play guitar and percussion
is that right yeah you know i dabble in
a lot guitar is my main instrument but
uh you know
everybody plays percussion right we all
drum on our desk i guess so
even if it's in the air we play it
and you're and what's the name of your
band well house band of the universe is
the band that i've
actually toured around with some that's
a little pretentious i would think
i mean i don't i don't think there's
going to be like you know a lot of
a lot of competition well there might be
but so far nobody has
you know like complained from another uh
part of the universe another galaxy if
they did that would be kind of cool so
i think with with that name he'd be the
shoe-in for the earth
representation in the star wars bar
scene right
it'd be the earth earth folks yeah yeah
definitely uh is boba fett a member of
your band
there's one guy that looks a little bit
like boba fett i think it might be
related
[Laughter]
there's one guy that comes to practice
with a helmet on every time
that's a little i will say this though
it would be super cool
if some aliens showed up here and they
were just like
yo man we're the house band of the
universe
battle of the bands yeah
yeah but if you get some alien that has
sort of multiple
mouths uh they could be their own
trumpet section for example you know you
got to watch out
because we design our instruments to fit
our the limits of our own limbs
and other aliens could totally uh so for
example
for example the house band in the movie
um little mermaid that sebastian sang
with i think the octopus might have been
on the drums
i i have some memory the octopus in the
band and there's no way you can beat an
octopus with eight limbs that's not
alternative
alternative anatomies could have the
edge but you know there's this guy i
think it's
rashawn roland kirk who can play like
two or three flutes and saxophones at
the same time and he uses like his
nostrils and stuff so
um we might have to get creative if we
want to beat those
right so are you a fan of science
fiction
oh absolutely yeah you know uh i think
you'd be hard-pressed to find a space
scientist who wasn't on some level
uh steeped in science fiction and yeah
but if you're an astrobiologist so much
of what we're looking for
in a sci-fi film is it's not just oh
look at the pretty space shots it's
how are they representing their aliens
so could you give me sort of a starter
list
of what we think an alien
should look like and then later on we'll
talk about what they're
they might actually look like or sorry
or how hollywood might be representing
them well you know what they would
actually look like it's not even
something we spend that much time on
where we
worry much more about like what would
they eat and breathe but as far as what
they would look like
i go back to like the sort of common
like fractal
architecture of a lot of earth you know
if you look at
a lot of life on earth if you look at
trees and blood vessels and brains
there's the kind of commonality that
makes sense if you're making something
complex out of simple parts
so i i picture that some of that
geometry
that's kind of universal in life on
earth would also be
universal for life off of earth so so we
might see some familiar forms just
because sort of the physics
of self-organization leads to kind of
common forms
i love what you said there and i just
want to emphasize it you're talking
about
fractal structures and what's
interesting about fractals is
it can give the illusion of complexity
but it's really a very simple basic
design that gets copied
many times and in many ways it might is
that a fair characterization of that
sentence
absolutely and and it comes out of a lot
of like sort of the physical need if you
think of like
blood vessels or trees absorbing
sunlight making branches you know you're
trying to maximize surface area
with the smallest number of modular
parts and so you evolve this sort of
branching structure
and those kind of physical needs will
exist anywhere where there's life
so that makes me think well maybe
there'll be some things that kind of
look
recognizable about aliens interesting
let me go straight to my first clip
with andy weir the title of his book is
project
hail mary and it's about an exotic kind
of life
that's threatening all life
on earth possibly rendering it extinct
so let's check it out basically the main
problem
that humanity is facing is there's a
microbe an extraterrestrial microbe
called astrophage or at least that's
what humans name it it's um you know
only about it's about the size of a
bacteria it's about 20 pico meters
across
and it lives on the surface of stars and
so it's kind of like an
algae that lives on stars and it
collects energy
um through most of its life and then
uses that energy
via it stores it as mass and then uses
that energy
to propel itself to a planet so it can
get the elements it needs to reproduce
because there's really nothing to be
found on a star except for hydrogen and
helium
and then um the problem is this is
breeding out of control in our star
and all the local stars by the way and
it's causing the sun to dim
and once the sun gets dim enough the
food chain on earth will collapse and
everything will die
so that is the problem that they're
facing what a happy story thank you
that has been andy weir on star talk
so you're this is a twist on ways in
which an organism a microscopic organism
could render us extinct
right it's not messing with us it's
messing with the sun oh my gosh
so but it's not it doesn't care it's not
intelligent it's just
living its best life um astrophage can
travel interstellar distances
um kind of like mold it just spores out
in all directions and
one in every 10 to the whatever of them
will actually find
another star so is the is mold
spores the the closest terrestrial
analog
to this either mold spores or um
or algae oceanic algae so so
david andy weir's first book the martian
didn't involve alien life it was human
life on mars so with the clever title
the martian the martian was
humans on mars in that case matt damon
of course
so so so here's andy going into alien
life
and so how do you think about
this it's kind of clever that it's
killing us not by
attacking us but by influencing
something that we depend on
so that's a that's a nice little sort of
alien twist but
are are you cool with how he's coming at
this subject
yeah i like it it's it's clever uh you
know and it reminds me there are
certainly organisms on earth that
uh that live parasitically and choke off
the
the uh energy supplies of other
organisms whether this could happen on a
stellar level
um you know it's pretty outrageous and
part of me thinks well
part of me thinks if something could eat
stars then something would be eating
stars and then we'd
notice because we understand the energy
balance of stars pretty well
so i'm reassured that i don't think this
is actually out there happening
but that doesn't mean it doesn't make a
cool science fiction idea well wait so
your best evidence is the absence of
evidence
all right i guess that's the evidence
you're putting forth i haven't seen it
yet so
i don't think it's going to happen i
don't know biologically life is so
opportunistic that if it was doable
it would already be out there doing it
and then
you know we've seen a lot of stars and
we understand their energy balance
pretty well
so i'm skeptical that astrophage is
really out there eating a lot of stars
in the galaxy but that's okay that
doesn't
like to me diminish the coolness of
using this for
a sci-fi story as something that would
present quite a problem if it were
happening here
so now you you study uh atmospheric
conditions on other planets
so how much have you thought about
sort of the climactic catastrophe
with regard to aliens because that's
basically what andy ware's describing
here
yeah well a lot i mean certainly there's
a history
even on earth of climatic catastrophe
climactic catastrophe the middle c
in there as a musician i should know
about middle school
the totally get your middle c straight
yes so
you know there's even a history on earth
of of uh the climate being
wrecked by runaway life you know you
think of what we call the oxygen
catastrophe
two and a half billion years ago where
blue-green algae
um you know first of all they poison the
air with oxygen so a lot of
organisms that can't handle oxygen went
extinct and we think it also caused a
climate catastrophe because it was
around
when uh what we call snowball earth
happened the earth went into a deep
freeze
and it was probably the result of those
organisms pumping oxygen
and messing with the greenhouse effect
messing with methane
and plunging the earth into a deep
freeze so so the idea that little
tiny organisms could screw up the
climate of a planet
and uh cause a big problem for life is
is uh
not at all outrageous in fact i think
it's happened here you don't
need aliens for that could that happen
here on earth
so basically all we're doing when we uh
in effect caught not in effect when we
cause climate change
all we're doing is returning the earth
to its natural state
right i mean so no no problem right
no to a different state
that's one that's one moral you could
take away from this it's like well hey
it's been done before
you screwed up the climate so right you
know yeah we lost
70 80 90 of all species at times that's
fine that's fine earth
earth is cool let's find out um it's the
circle of life
we're not even original it's a circle
that might not include
us yes right so andy where told me about
how
astrophage sort of captures and uses
energy
uh but there's also what we know from
life as we know it
three properties that
uh seem to be present in all life forms
so one is that it's carbon-based
another is that it uses liquid water and
another is that there's some kind of a
metabolism
for life as we know it so now here's
another kind of life let's see what andy
ware says about
it it has all three of those because as
we come to learn here's a spoiler
um all of the life in this book
the alien life and the earth life came
from a single panspermia event
so um astrophage in fact has
mitochondria
and ribosomes and everything so
i did that partially to explain why
there was life on
you know so close together you know the
odds
whatever numbers you want to put into
the drake equation the odds that
life would happen you know really really
close and one of the stars within 20
light years seems
really slim just given this to the size
of the whole universe
yeah right and so i i decided well it's
a panspermia event because
something evolved that is able to travel
travel interstellar distances
so that's what seeded life around our
local cluster
so it's got dna it's got dna it's got
it's got dna rna transcription ribosomes
uh mitochondria which are the powerhouse
of the cell and everything else
now you asked what i added to it i also
added
um their cell membrane this is the
complete made-up part of the physics
so i'm sure you'll appreciate it um the
astrophage cell membrane
has this method of turning heat energy
into
um it takes a hydrogen ion aka proton
collisions
and turns the energy of those collisions
into
two neutrinos um balancing the momentum
and and becoming the energy and then
the energy for it to live or the energy
for it to propulse
for pulse this is this is how it stores
energy it turns heat energy
in other words the the um speed of these
hydrogen atoms
uh it turns that into neutrinos and it
has a magical ability to store neutrinos
and so i say that it its cell membrane
has a
feature which nobody understands how
it's doing it uh
super cross sectionality it is not
possible for anything to quantum tunnel
through this
wow and so then it sends the neutrinos
out for its own
um to recoil from that and that's its
propulsion not quite it uses a neutrinos
to store it
then when it wants to do propulsion it
it forces the neutrinos to collide
into each other because their arena
particles so they will self-annihilate
because
it's an anti-matter antimatter reaction
and then
they will turn into um
photons that work out to be in the
infrared spectrum because of the energy
so so david
before we get into sort of the neutrino
physics
of astrophage uh could you remind us
what the drake equation is because he
just made fast
uh use of that term sure yeah the drake
equation is
um a sort of um very simple
actually formulation that we use when
we're discussing
the probability of life and the sort of
density the amount of life and
intelligent life that might exist in our
galaxy or in the universe as a whole so
it's a way where we say if we estimate
this amount
this number of stars have habitable
planets and this percentage of the
planets
have conditions that have actually
evolved life and this percentage have
complex life etc you put in all your
assumptions
and you can adjust the levels and then
you crank through that and you get
uh how much life there is in the galaxy
so it's basically just a way of
quantitatively having a conversation
about how much life there was in the
galaxy
and so all right so that's the frequency
of life now the kind of life that it is
so often in science fiction where
we're looking for aliens walking with
ray guns
and here he's describing something
algae-like
all right and at one point in the
interview
he had referred to ben bova's great
science fiction author
ajayid only just in 2020
in 1992 he wrote a book called mars
where the life forms there were
more like they were sort of algae-like
uh
living on the surface of a cave so if we
want to think of
most likely kind of life we might find
how does allergy type life
compete with other forms of life that
you can dream up
well i mean algae is a good design
for life on planets you know i'm not
sure
uh how it's going to fair interstellar
space but
you know algae is basically simple uh
very simple
uh life that uh uses sunlight
and doesn't have to be sunlight
starlight of any kind and
um you know it's sort of a basic design
that we would uh it's very plausible to
me that we would find something like it
probably wouldn't be exactly terrestrial
algae unless you believe in
you know this total span [ __ ] of you
but but that that kind of design
for for a life form makes a lot of sense
and i
it wouldn't shock me to find something
that was kind of algae-like
on another world and give me a
two-sentence definition of panspermia
transpermia well it means uh you know
seeds across
it's just the idea that life instead of
forming
uh uh having an independent origin on
each world could actually form on one
world uh perhaps long ago and then
spread from world world naturally
so chuck that sounds like a guy came up
with that term doesn't it um
without a doubt a guy did come up with
that term
you know what i mean it's not it's not
pan ovulation
like it's transparent
yeah don't get excited
we got to take a quick break when we
come back we're going to find out what
what the aliens in andy ware's book have
to do with climate change on star talk
we're back on star talk got chuck nice
chuck you're tweeting at chuck nice
comic let's go check that out yeah
very nice nice and we're featuring my
interview with andy weir
author of the martian book he wrote six
seven years ago
uh we all most of us saw the film but it
has a latest book
called project hail mary it's got aliens
possibly rendering
life on earth extinct and we've got
friend of star talk
david grinspoon who's going to help us
out here
david in the first segment you mentioned
that your band was called the house band
of the universe
but during the pandemic i don't suppose
you played in many places
right no we uh it's impossible or it's
been impossible to
actually perform um but i have
been playing with a local pickup band of
musicians around washington dc
um sort of in a socially distant or
online way and we've been calling
ourselves a band damage
[Laughter]
very good yeah i like that pandemic
pandemic dude i don't know how that's
going to play a few years from now but
right now
yeah right now yeah get all your gigs in
now because yeah people look at you in
five years
what the hell is wrong with you all
right okay well listen if
guess what if you said if you told a kid
today that you like pearl jam they'd be
like we'll put some on my toast
so
it's that sparkly jam that's right right
exactly
so what's interesting about andy ware's
latest book
is it actually touches on climate change
and what power we might have to
influence it one way or another
all caused by this alien organism that's
threatening us
so let's check out what this connection
might be
and how it could lead to environmental
catastrophe check it out
i came up with a problem first and i you
know okay it'll affect earth
and what's interesting is um it's
mentioned in the book that
the damage we've done to the climate
actually helps
make us last longer because
the earth has stored up more heat energy
than it normally would have
as a result and so we actually although
it's not much it's like a complete
different scale when you're starting to
mess with the solar luminance so it's
like
oh yeah we we get about like one extra
month
you know because it undoes all of that
and actually in the book there are
people doing everything they can
to increase the greenhouse effect
so that we can retain as much of the
energy that's hitting earth as possible
with the reduced solar output
okay so this is a twist on what we're
trying to do right now
to you know i mean not intentionally i'm
not making any sort of political
allegory i'm just like
these would be the consequences like if
the sun started dimming
then not enough energy's hitting earth
oh interesting we've been collecting too
much energy lately
oh now we need to really collect a lot
more you figured out
that the climate deniers are beginning
to outnumber
the climate scientists and so you want
to get all them
to read your book well i don't know if
my book is a really good
uh thing for you know for a science
denier
right yeah okay well also but also i
don't think it's a really good thing
because
the only way that climate change comes
into it is either
a as sort of a a good thing that helped
by us another month
and b as a thing that everybody has to
deliberately do
to try to make earth last as long as
possible during this crisis
so they bring out you bring out the
the the hummers and worse than that they
have to do
they have to do global warming on a
massive massive scale so i come up with
what i think is a pretty clever way
um they actually use a bunch of nuclear
weapons
like a a bunch of nuclear weapons to
clean you know all put up in a line to
cleave off a big
chump a big chunk of antarctic ice shelf
which then goes into the ocean and melts
over time releasing all the methane
that's in the ice
wow and the methane is great because it
um
it is a huge greenhouse gas yeah yeah
way bigger than co2 that's right yeah
it's a massive greenhouse gas
and it will kind of degrade over about
10 years so they're hoping
that they can solve the problem and then
once they solve the problem
then the sun will get back to normal
luminance and then they don't want to
have all that greenhouse
gas but it's great because methane will
degrade and go away in about 10 years
so what he did say in his book is that
the
the quantitative effects of this is that
earth's temperature
would drop by 10 to 15 degrees
in the next 30 years so we're talking
about
re-uh adding
all manner of greenhouse gases over a
short period of time to
counteract this son you're my hero
[Laughter]
everybody more beef let's eat beef
come on let's eat beef in your hummer
doing a tailgate party exactly
so so yeah but you don't want to kill
off all the cows because they're adding
methane too so
you're adding methane too exactly
exactly so
so david what is your give me your
general thoughts on geoengineering just
as a thing
well you know geoengineering makes a
cool
um physics problem in
in a simple way you know for like you
know that i assigned to my atmospheric
science students like how much
methane or how much of co2 would you
have to add to heat up or how much dust
would you have to put in the atmosphere
to cool down by so many degrees
in a very simple modeling form the
problem is when you actually try to do
it to a planet
there's a lot of complexity that we
don't fully understand
and um so the
way so chuck that's code for we're not
smart enough
just right yeah when a scientist said
well this is not yet understood
scientists will never say we're too
stupid to figure it out they'll never
say that
in this case let me tell you something
those are the kind of scientists that i
really like because when you talk about
screwing around with the earth's like
you know
with its with its weather systems and
geoengineering
i i'd rather you just go yeah i don't i
don't know
i don't know people talk about
you know putting up dust or aerosols to
you know this is a real proposal some
people have to fight global warming
and it works in a simple energy balanced
way you can say yeah you're going to cut
down the sunlight that much and the
greenhouse would go down this much and
it works
but the details of earth's uh
circulation and the actual motions of
the atmosphere you know it's really true
we aren't smart enough our best models
can't really predict what that's going
to do to the monsoon in india
and it's going to cause you know it
could cause drought and famine
and so uh when i hear this it's like
yeah if it's a lasted
ditch effort because otherwise earth is
going to just be
totally hosed then we would probably be
justified in trying something like that
but in any other situation it's really
not a good idea to mess with
mother nature it's not nice too
but and and and david when you agree
that a great way of geo engineering
would be to stop burning fossil fuels
right another kind of engineering yeah
right
i mean doing something intentionally
to fix the climate then stopping burning
fossil fuels
planting trees those are good forms of
geoengineering that are
maybe a little less risky wait wait so
so david are there any life forms that
could
fully exploit a a
a massive geo-engineering shift on the
short time scale
uh evolution takes longer than that of
course but
are there any life forms that are just
on the edge of pouncing
and then if the world gets warmer all of
a sudden they're in charge
is there it's got to be fast the answer
has to be yes
because think about the climate zones on
earth earth does not all have the same
climate at different latitudes so if you
uh warm up say the poles then
organisms that are comfortable in the
tropics are going to move in
you know so uh because of that there are
definitely organisms that are poised
to exploit any shift in climate uh it's
you know
life on earth would carry on it's just
it might not include
humans after it oh there's a little
detail
who says that look so casually right
exactly
by the way honey i'm never coming home
again like that's
i'll be back never never right so
also in andy's book the astrophage
creates an
arc that connects the sun with
venus's atmosphere apparently it needs
the co2
in venus's atmosphere so is there a
um what can you tell us about
the possibility of life on venus in
general and just and its co2 supply
in particular well um
there are some scientists myself
included who have been arguing for the
possibility
of life in the clouds of venus um
just because you know unlike the surface
which
would be you know completely off limits
to organic life because it's just too
hot for
organic matter to survive at all the
clouds are kind of
moderate in temperature and there are
energy sources different you know sort
of
um chemicals you can imagine something
would eat there's plenty of radiation
uh you would have an ecosystem unto
themselves is what you're saying
could be could be yeah i mean you would
have to survive the extreme
acidic conditions and there are
different opinions on whether life could
actually
do that although there are you know
extremophile organisms on earth that
love acid um caves and things so um
you know interestingly enough in the
context of
this story there's some mysterious stuff
in the upper atmosphere of venus that's
absorbing
a ton of solar energy and we call it the
unknown ultraviolet absorber and
at least um in my view it's fun to
speculate that it could be some weird
biological pigment that can absorb in
the ultraviolet which of course is
the photons in the ultraviolet have tons
of energy if life could learn to exploit
them but of course
chuck doesn't doesn't sound like chuck
doesn't sound like the name of a
dc superhero villain in dc comics
the unknown ultraviolet absorber yeah
i'm just thinking that sounds completely
diabolical yeah but he's got to be a uh
because he's unknown so he has to be a
villain
yeah yeah of course yeah no not a
superhero i'm talking about superhero
villain
yeah absolutely yeah and i got to tell
you david you just came up with a better
science fiction movie
movie than than i'm sorry i guess
because quite frankly i'm all about the
life forms the cloud people of venus
i'm all about that okay hi i'm celestia
one of the cloud people of venus
you'll notice my dewy skin due to the
acidic atmosphere that gives me a
natural chemical peel
like that's cool
so we also talked about the tech in his
story because you can't have science
fiction without
technology and so let's find out what he
tells us about it
i try to keep everything uh as realistic
as possible and
the closer you the closer you are to
real existing technology and your story
the closer you're going to be to
scientific reality and act
and accuracy in project hail mary
actually it's kind of funny because it's
really
the only technology we have in that book
is the technology we have right now
today
plus astrophage that's it and so they
use they
figure out a way to make a propulsion
system that uses astrophage
and um also like for they're in a huge
hurry to get this mission going they're
sending a ship to tau ceti
with scientists aboard and they want to
have a lab
and they say like we don't have time to
invent
0g versions of all of this lab equipment
we don't have time to invent a 0g
scanning electron microscope
a 0g 5-axis mill 0g this that and the
other thing
so instead they say we're going to make
the ship have a centrifuge mode
and use normal well-tested lab equipment
and so his lab in this extremely
advanced spaceship has like
110 ac power outlets
because okay because he's using like
off-the-shelf
like laboratory technology that's been
tested with like millions of man hours
and they they need
him to have reliable stuff you know
that's an interesting point
correct me if i'm wrong dave because
we're about the same age i think
the apollo saturn v rocket
was basically off-the-shelf items i mean
i don't think we had to invent anything
remarkably new
unusual or different for that rocket
though the rocket with it was without
precedence that's my understanding
of that time which is how we could get
it done so quickly wow
yeah certainly a lot of the individual
components were things that were being
used uh commonly in other you know the
electronics and so forth
uh i'm not sure about all the the
materials
in the uh in the um rocket engines
themselves that might have been a little
bit of
required a little innovation but
certainly uh you know the bulk of
the uh the components were things that
already existed
now what i like about it is we
effectively reverse engineer this
this mysterious propulsion system of
astrophage
and then we then use it for ourself so
are you um and it uses light propulsion
right or any uh well
is it fair to say use light propulsion
if it has a matter anti-matter
generator inside of it using neutrinos
then
it's it's uh so
let's let's make that the point so so
david where are we now in terms of
matter anti-matter
drive because star trek clearly has it
and so does everybody else
yeah we're we're we're uh it's i would
say it's not right around the corner
we have i love the way you two that was
great
that was the best scientific answer i've
ever heard
no i mean not right around the corner
not right around the corner we have
we have isolated antimatter now which is
pretty cool
but i mean individual particles you know
like uh
positrons you know which are um
[Music]
you know the the anti-matter
complement of of electrons we have
individual particles
we we're far from being able to produce
or gather somehow a bulk amount of
antimatter
and then use it as propulsion but
you want you understand it makes sense
why
that um it works why it's a good idea in
science fiction and let you know that
star trek was was really smart to use it
because it's absolutely true that
anti-matter exists
and the energy density of um
anti-matter is something you know you
can react with ordinary matter
and just with a tiny you know tiniest
amount of fuel create
unbelievably huge amounts of energy you
know and it's real physics
so um it's a great idea for science
fiction it's not
uh i don't see it for practical
implementation happening anytime soon
not not around the corner okay so
when we come back we'll talk more about
applying
known technologies to the future of
space travel
with david winston on star talk
we're back star talk we're trying to
think about
aliens in space and technology in space
and
we talked about climate change as as
how an alien could render us extinct or
how we might even render ourselves
extinct
uh and i've got a chuck nice as always
and dr funky spoon
yes a david grinspoon
that's very 1978. ah you know because
it's funky baby it's funky
yeah that's the peak funk period right
there right
make my funk the defunct okay
my mother never goes out of style there
you go
yeah it's not that it goes out style you
might leave it but it's always in style
right that's right that's it so we were
discussing
we were featuring my interview with andy
weir and his book project
hail mary and uh let's go right into
the one and only clip we have of that
conversation for this segment
and we're just talking about current
technologies and
how how how we doing what's our report
card on that let's check it out
spacex really is doing what we should be
doing um
mostly the main thing that spacex is
doing that i deeply approve of is
driving down the price of getting mass
into low earth orbit
because that's the key to everything if
we can get that price driven down
further and further and further
we will eventually reach a point where a
middle-class person can afford uh a
space vacation
like you know it'll cost like 10 000
bucks to go
you know or maybe 20 000 or something
like that to go stay in a space hotel
for
a week or something if you can get it
down to that level
um then you will have a multi-trillion
dollar space industry it'll be for
profit
and that will spur more innovation and
uh in the space technology you know
david
here's a concern i have which in fact
was the subject of more than one film
if we start sending people into space
could there be space microbes that
contaminate
them and then they bring that down here
to earth do we know enough about now
neil has made a better
uh sci-fi movie than andy weir
i'm just saying is it is there you know
we talk about oh someone caught a bug in
some other country or some other
continent
now we're space is part of our our
our biosphere in a sense now right as
well
you have to get tons of shots before you
go to other countries
and that's what so can you comment on
the toxicity of aliens
yeah well i mean the andromeda strain
was uh you know for one
it still really holds up as a pretty
good film
um well chuck is too young he won't
remember so chuck do you know who wrote
the andromeda strain oh
heck no okay but you should okay well
the same guy who wrote jurassic park oh
get out of christian
michael creighton and that was and
andromeda strain was his
first big breakthrough book in in film
and you know when he wrote that while he
was in medical school
so here we have talented people who are
learning
science and then they tell it weave a
tale of science fiction
with the science that they've learned so
i think there are a lot of untold
stories here because not all scientists
are novelists
and then they realize they can make
really big bucks
[Laughter]
yeah he said forget this this medical
profession
well i mean isaac isaac asimov was a uh
biochemistry professor at boston
university and he
he wrote his first few science fiction
novels under a pseudonym paul french
because he didn't want anybody to know
he was writing sci-fi and then he was
like hey
i can do pretty well with this so tell
me about the toxicity of aliens
yeah so i'm cautious we need to be i'm
not that worried about
life in space being able to survive
on earth and infect us because
even though i liked the science fiction
idea as we've been discussing of
microbes that could possibly find a way
to persist in the space environment i
think that they would be
fundamentally different physically in
fact even
the sort of rule of water and organics
and energy that we were talking about
might not apply i mean that's a
great way to make life on the surface of
a planet where liquid water
and organic chemistry do well but in
space you've got all this
intense radiation and i think if there
was life out there you'd be looking at a
really fundamentally different basis
and therefore the idea that it could
come and thrive
and infect us here on the surface of a
planet
seems much less plausible to me that's
why my favorite
sci-fi uh films are when the
uh aliens land and they breathe our air
or they're exposed to our elements of
any kind
and they die oh they die well no
that would mean they okay not that they
can affect us but if they can be
affected by our microbes that's the same
two-way street right yeah so so from
another planet
i think is more plausible but actually
microbes
that are adapted to the environment in
space living on earth
seems harder to me um but like the idea
of martians you know that it's that's
the plot of the war of the worlds right
the martians get defeated not by our
guns but
by they get infected with a common coal
right
nice um you know i still don't know if
the metabolism on another planet would
be similar enough
that animals could be infected by their
microbes but
it seems plausible to me more plausible
than actual space microbes whatever they
might be
making let me let me ask you both this
then okay
forget the space microbes let's say we
have
a world where over a period of time that
world is slowly losing its atmosphere
as it does so it loses its protection
against radiation
and therefore whatever life is there has
been an
adaptation to a world that
had um that that have protection from
radiation to a world that has none
but it continued to live then somehow it
lands here
would it be able to survive good one
really interesting question
um the
i would think that whatever adaptation
it made
to living without air would probably
make it harder
for it to suddenly live again in a
planet with air
but you know one thing we've learned
about life is how opportunistic it is
and if it had originally involved it
originally evolved on a planet with
there maybe it would have this sort of
vestigial metabolism
that could be re-triggered in that
environment
so i don't know chuck now i think you
just came up with a science fiction
story
you know we have five novels here and
none of us are novelists
so let's geek out here for a minute
um going on wait wait i have we're gonna
have a geek moment but before that
um david what are the ethics of
either purposefully or inadvertently
spreading our microbes to
other possible fertile environments out
there
interesting it's a really interesting
question and a lot of people are
debating this now uh you know the sort
of
first blush answer that a lot of people
come up with is like how dare we
why should we you know screw up other
planets what we've done to our own
planet
but there's a reverse argument that's
pretty interesting which is that
if there's another environment that is
lifeless
maybe mars is completely lifeless then
if we have the opportunity to bring life
elsewhere in the universe then isn't
that a good thing there's kind of a deep
ecology
rationale deep ecology is the philosophy
that um reveres
life above everything even above humans
it says all life is valuable innately
and if mars is truly a dead world
then maybe there's something ethically
positive about
letting it flourish and then again we're
now we're the progenitors of panspermia
yeah but in that case exactly truck
right so yeah
so so but uh is it is am i mistaken if
i'm remembering correctly that uh the
reason why we crashed cassini
was for that reason not to infect
yeah that's right we have we have
planetary protection protocols we have
rules about uh you do everything you can
to avoid
inadvertently contaminating a planet
especially a planet where life could
possibly thrive
and because we plunked cassini into
jupiter so by that measure we
contaminated jupiter so what are you
saying
right so while we point cassini explain
your way out of that one
we function into saturn but we plug
galileo into jupiter
for similar reasons and wouldn't it be
ironic if by doing so we had
contaminated those worlds because the
point of doing that was because that's a
place we surely couldn't contaminate
because those are just going to burn up
and those are such weird alien worlds
but the moons
of saturn and jupiter are places we
imagine there might be underground life
in in sealed in oceans you know both on
on uh
on uh enceladus around saturn on europa
around jupiter
so we've been very careful not to crash
spacecraft onto those places
although as you point out neil we maybe
we just killed officers
i was going to say neil just exposed a
glaring
arrogance that we have with respect to
where we believe life might be we just
killed off all the jupiterians you know
we thought we were being so careful
practicing safe
planetary exploration no in all fairness
if you do the math
the kinetic energy of the craft as it
collides with jupiter's atmosphere
is sufficiently high that when all that
gets converted to thermal energy
you basically vaporize the entire craft
so i think we're safe here you basically
burned your burned your garbage
let's geek out for a minute david i'm
sure you've thought about this
but since science fiction authors
reference you and
dedicate their books to you could you
could you what's your most
fantastical dreams for space exploration
and space travel right now
where would you give me a little most of
what we know but give me a little bit of
what we don't know
put it together and dream it and what
comes out of your head
well so for you know there's there's
what is there's like what is my most
fantastic
dream for some far future and that
involves
maybe like what we call generation ships
where um groups of humans
that are self-sustaining could could not
only live
in in space and orbital communities as
it has been described but then those
could
migrate to other stars um
it's sort of a i think it's just
something sort of beautiful about this
idea of sort of
the slow interstellar migration but if
we're talking about
wait wait just to be clear just to be
clear you
are committing an entire generation of
unborn people to be prisoners of a
spaceship that
you came up with to send to another
planet
yeah you're saying it's beautiful well
it's not without
this i looked at ethical um challenges
but
but how is that how is that different
really from listen
listen you gotta love the way david
checked i told him i gotta tell you what
what david just said
was sometimes when you take a trip
that's
not right around the corner people know
people think about it may not have a
choice but how is that really different
from people that migrate
anywhere and then they assume that their
kids and their grandkids are going to
want to live there people
because because you could get on an
airplane and go back back
well you okay all right i was going to
say david that's an excellent point
however
that's uh that's kind of checkmate there
you're right because you can't come back
but hey my my dream for the next you
know
few decades it involves
the fact that miniaturization is getting
so good
and that we can do so much you know in
my own field of planetary exploration
there are these really far out ideas
that are becoming plausible where we can
send
tiny spacecraft to other planets you
know things like
cubesats that are cheap which are
literally
um you know postage stamp sized um
tiny little um spacecraft basically you
can drop
into a planetary atmosphere and they
have uh scientific instruments built
onto a chip that can do pretty
sophisticated things
and you could drop a swarm of these into
the atmosphere of venus
or mars or jupiter and learn all kinds
of things about the chemistry and the
circulation
and it wouldn't be very expensive so i
feel like the
innovation that's coming just from our
being able to make really sophisticated
really
tiny things is going to allow us to
explore the solar system in a more
thorough way
without sending all that much stuff or
spending so low mass payloads
so yeah
they do very well with acceleration and
propulsion
because the same force will accelerate
it much higher than if you're sending a
whole human being
for example so yeah so if
and then it comes and that means it's
just going to not cost nearly as much
and that's
that is very enabling so what uh if you
were
to go i mean just what is so i guess
proxima
would be about four light years or four
years
proxima century yeah yeah four likes so
so
would we be able to would we'd be able
to do anything in our lifetime
let's say we had that capability i mean
that's that's the other side of this uh
that's the other side of this
miniaturization technology you know
there's this group now with a
breakthrough
um with starshot where they're talking
about using postage
stamp size spacecraft and accelerating
them with powerful lasers from earth to
some significant fraction of the speed
of light
and getting to the nearest planetary
systems
in something like um you know in decades
rather than so
this is this is an array a very high
powered lasers
being sent from earth to these traveling
um mini uh spaceships they were there we
call them that
and and that will accelerate them from
what i've read
maybe as high as 20 the speed of light
is that wow correct
right yeah so it'll be twenty years
there right because it's
twenty percent of you know light years
yeah so it's five oh
that is that is so dope
yeah it is alive today who will be
around
but then you only get confirmation of it
when it tells you back at the speed of
light
so it's a 24-year confirmation that it
that it arrived
yes and there's no there's no magic
involved it's all known
physics the technology is pushing things
but there's no magic tricks it's just
developing things we already know how to
do to some extreme okay
chuck i gotta hear david's response to
this ready okay so david
uh what happens to an airplane that
flies accidentally into the
laser beams that are propelling these
oh that would be an unfortunate
[Laughter]
20 20 years later that laser beam is on
proxima
oh man you're losing 747 every now and
then but that's worth it right
okay mistakes were made
that's hilarious all right we're gonna
have to actually call it quits there
but um but chuck always good to have you
as my colleagues a pleasure
i want to thank andy weir for agreeing
to you know jump onto our
our into our star talk universe and
share with us his latest projects uh
he's been a fan of our work
and we're definitely a fan of his so we
don't even want to miss whatever he's up
to
and uh david always good to see you and
to talk to you
we go way back even well before star
talk and so it's great to see you
still connected with us um what i'd like
to do
to end is give a recitation
of uh one of the
concluding passages of h.g wells war of
the worlds
just to take us out if you'll indulge me
go for it and by you know war of the
worlds has a narrator
in the movie the tom cruise version of
it there's an error you know who
narrated it
uh was it um wait give me a second um oh
god
more morgan free man
okay so i remember andy dufresne
and his alien friend
so generally you if if you have to guess
a narrator it's
50 chance it's going to be morgan
freeman in fact it was him i'm not going
to read his ending narration because
it it made some changes from the
original
here's the original and this will take
us out okay just to remind you aliens
from
mars attacked humans they fell sick and
died
because they caught some microbe that
we all had immunity to and it did not so
here it goes
for so it had come about as indeed i and
many men
might have foreseen had not terror and
disaster
blinded our minds these germs of disease
have taken toll of humanity since the
beginning of things
taken toll of our pre-human ancestors
since life began here by virtue
of this natural selection of our kind we
have developed resisting power
to no germs do we succumb without a
struggle
and directly these invaders arrived
directly they drank
and fed our microscopic allies began to
work their
overthrow already when i had watched
them they were
irrevocably doomed dying and rotting
even as they went to and fro it was
inevitable
by the toll of a billion deaths man has
bought his birthright of the earth and
it is his
against all comers it will still be his
were the martians ten times as mighty as
they are
for neither do men live nor die
in vain
there's hg wells for you yeah had a way
with words
man all right this has been star talk
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist as always
keep looking up